>> Dagen: A DEMOCRAT-LET HOUSE
COMMITTEE HOLDING ITS FIRST
HEARING ON THE JANUARY 6 CAPITAL
RIOT, POLICE OFFICERS ON DUTY
THAT DAY GIVING DRAMATIC
TESTIMONY ON WHAT THEY
WITNESSED.
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI UNDER FIRE
FOR BLOCKING TWO REPUBLICAN
NOMINEES TO THE PANEL, THE
DEMOCRATS AREN'T HAPPY WITH
THEIR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
EITHER, ADAM SCHIFF SAYING THIS
ABOUT LEADER McCARTHY BEFORE
THE HEARING EVEN STARTED.
>> THAT REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT
WAS WILLING TO DO THAT IN 2001
AND 2002 IS NOT DONALD TRUMP'S
REPUBLICAN PARTY, IT HAD KEVIN
McCARTHY HAVE BEEN THE LEADER
THEN THERE WOULD'VE BEEN NO 9/11
COMMISSION, THERE WOULD'VE BEEN,
YOU KNOW, AN EFFORT TO PERSUADE
THE COUNTRY THAT IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN OR IT'S OVERBLOWN OR WHO
KNOWS WHAT THE ACCLAMATION
WOULD'VE BEEN.
>> Dagen: REPUBLICAN HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY
BLASTING PELOSI AND CALLING THE
HEARING A SHAM.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, SPEAKER PELOSI
WILL ONLY PICK ON PEOPLE ON THE
COMMITTEE THAT WILL ASK THE
QUESTION SHE WANTS ASKED.
THAT BECOMES A FAILED COMMITTEE,
A SHAM THAT NO ONE CAN BELIEVE.
IF YOU WANT THE TRUE ANSWERS, DO
NOT BE AFRAID OF THE QUESTIONS I
WILL GET ASKED.
>> Dagen: GREG, HAVE AT IT.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO PREFACE
WHAT WE'VE ALWAYS SET ON THE
SHOW RIGHT OFF THE BAT, WE
CONDEMN EQUALLY THE RIGHTS OF
LAST YEAR, THE BILLIONS IN
DAMAGES AND JANUARY 6 BECAUSE AS
CONSERVATIVES OR LIBERTARIANS OR
REPUBLICANS, WE HAVE A GATE THAT
PREVENTS THE BARBARIANS FROM
STORMING AND ON JANUARY 6TH WE
BECAME THE BARBARIANS, WE DON'T
LIKE THAT.
HAVING SAID THAT, IT WOULD BE
FUN TO DO A HEARING ON THE CRIME
WAVE AND INTERVIEW THE POLICE
FROM SEATTLE, PORTLAND,
MINNEAPOLIS, NEW YORK CITY JUST
TO PROVIDE REAL CONTEXT ABOUT
ACTUAL THREATS TO DEMOCRACY.
WE ARE BEING LECTURED BY PHONY
POLITICIANS ABOUT THREATS TO OUR
COUNTRY WHILE THEY IGNORE A
MOUNTING PILE OF DEAD END IT'S
ALL FOR POLITICS.
I ALSO REJECT THE IDEA THAT
HAVING POLITICIANS JOBS
DISRUPTED FOR TWO HOURS IS
SOMEHOW WORSE THAN BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN DISTRACTION AND
DOZENS OF DEATHS INCLUDING
POLICE OFFICERS.
THAT'S WHY I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
HEARING ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I AM
NOT -- I CAN'T STOMACH THE
CRYING, I CAN'T STOMACH THE
CRYING.
I SAW SOME REALLY BAD STUFF LAST
YEAR AND NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
LIFTED A FINGER, WHAT A
BACKWARDS WORLD WE LIVE IN WHERE
THE MEDIA DIDN'T GIVE TWO F'S
ABOUT POLICE OFFICERS GETTING
KILLED AND BUSINESSES GET
TORCHED, A FEMALE PROTESTER WAS
SHOT DEAD, POINT BLANK.
IMAGINE IF SHE WAS BLM, HOW
WOULD THIS TURN OUT DIFFERENTLY?
JUST THINK ABOUT THAT, THAT'S
WHY THIS IS A CIRCUS, THAT'S A
CLOWN SHOW AND I DON'T BUY THE
FAKE TEARS.
>> Dagen: THEY KEEP COMPARING
THIS TO 9/11.
I'D LIKE THEM TO CALL JUST A FEW
OF THE THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN WHO
LOST A MOTHER OR A FATHER ON
9/11.
THIS IS HIDEOUSNESS.
>> Dana: THAT TYPE OF
COMPARISON IS NOT NECESSARY,
THERE ARE 14 INVESTIGATIONS THAT
ARE UNDERWAY.
I THINK THERE'S 12 IN CONGRESS
AND ONE AT DOJ AND ONE IN FBI.
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS THAT
SHOULD BE ANSWERED AND I DO
THINK OF THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
OVERPLAYED THEIR HAND ON THE
POLITICS OF THIS AND ARE
OVERESTIMATING THE AMOUNT OF
VICTORY THEY ARE GETTING IN
TERMS OF POLITICS BUT THE
REPUBLICANS MIGHT BE
UNDERESTIMATING THE LIABILITY AS
WELL SO I WOULD LOVE TO GET SOME
ANSWERS TO SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS, IN PARTICULAR THE ONE
THING THAT IS INTERESTING IN THE
COMPARISON OF 9/11 I MIGHT WORK
WHICH IS WHY WASN'T THE
INFORMATION SHARED WITH THE
PEOPLE WHO NEEDED TO KNOW IN
ORDER TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
TO PREVENT IT IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
>> Dagen: AND THE DEMOCRATS,
GERALDO, DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE A
HEARING ABOUT THE EMERGENCE OF
COVID WHICH HAS KILLED 611,000
AMERICANS.
>> Geraldo: I TREASURE THAT
THE AUDIENCE AT FOX NEWS HAS
TOLERATED ME FOR 20 YEARS
KNOWING THAT I AM OUT OF STEP
WITH THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE
WATCHING RIGHT NOW.
I HATE WHEN I AGREE WITH ADAM
SCHIFF IT GIVES ME THE CREEPS.
LIZ CHENEY AND ADAM KINGS THERE
ARE MY FAVORITE REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE, THIS IS KEVIN
McCARTHY ON JANUARY 13TH 2021.
THE PRESIDENT BEARS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WEDNESDAY'S
ATTACK ON CONGRESS BY MOB
RIOTERS.
HE SHOULD HAVE IMMEDIATELY
DENOUNCED THE MOB WHEN HE SAW
WHAT WAS ON FOLDING."
THAT'S KEVIN McCARTHY, THE
MINORITY LEADER OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, SANCTIMONIOUS
LECTURER TELLING US THIS.
NOTHING HAPPENED, THAT'S LIKE
BLAMING THE PERSON WHO GETS SHOT
IN THE CHEST FOR NOT WEARING A
BULLETPROOF VEST, THEY ATTACKED
THEIR CAPITAL AND HOW DARE YOU,
GREG, SAY THAT THIS IS TWO HOURS
OF DISRUPTION.
THIS WAS THE WORST ATTACK, ON
THE CAPITAL --
D5 THESE JERKS WERE, AS THE
CORONAVIRUS WAS BEGINNING TO
SPREAD AROUND THE NATION WERE
BUSY IMPEACHING PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR A SECOND TIME.
>> Jesse: I WAS WATCHING A
HEARING ON MY PHONE AND
JESSE JR. PEAKS OUT OF HIS CRIB
THIS MORNING AND SAYS "DAD, IS
THIS ALL PELOSI HAS IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTION?"
I THINK THERE IS, WHAT, SIX
AGENCIES INVESTIGATING THIS
THING.
THIS IS JUST A SHOW TRIAL TO PUT
REPUBLICANS ON THE DEFENSE.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, THEY RAKE TO THIS
COMMITTEE, REPUBLICANS DON'T
EVEN HAVE A VOICE AND THEN THEY
FUND RAISE UP AND EVERYBODY
CRIES, WE KNOW THE GAME HERE.
A LOT OF RIOTERS WHEN AN
UNBROKEN BROKE INTO PEOPLE'S
BUSINESSES LAST SUMMER AND NO
ONE CARED AND THEY BROKE INTO
THE DEMOCRATS PLACE OF WORK,
THEY WANT TO THROW THE BOOK AT
HIM, LAST SUMMER THEY BAILED OUT
THE RIOTERS.
THEY BAILED OUT THE RIOTERS LAST
SUMMER.
>> Greg: I CARE ABOUT THE
SMALL BUSINESSMAN.
THEY ARE JUST AS IMPORTANT, BUT
HERE JUST AS IMPORTANT.
YOU SAID THAT THE CRIME WAS A
CIVIL RIGHTS BATTLE OF THE
GENERATION, ALL THOSE BUSINESSES
DESERVE EQUAL, EQUAL --
>> Geraldo: YOU ARE
DEFLECTING, YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
DEFLECTING TO TRY TO GET THE
EYES OFF THE CAPITAL, 500
PEOPLE -- HISTORY WILL JUDGE
YOU.
>> Greg: I WILL REPEAT WHAT
GREG SAID.
>> Dagen: BE CAREFUL ABOUT
USING THE WOR